I think a girl could could have planned
all of this Pretty Little Liars returns
June 21st and the girls are trying to
uncover uber A's identity but it could
be one of them I've always been saying
that like Spencer's a I would love it so
much it looks like there's a mo jeez it
looks like there's a D but then there's
also goober a how many are there over a
is the same person as ad and emoji
possibilities that that ad has a team
helping ad but I think that if the
easiest way to explain is ad was born
after Charlotte's death you think that
one of the girls could be uber a it's
always a possibility it's always a
possibility I will say that the that
question is one we've discussed in the
writers room what was the answer all of
the little liars could be a think of
that five-year gap right what could have
happened in that five-year gap that past
will help inform what they're doing now
I think there's like the head honcho
it's sort of like working with her
little or his little minions so it could
be arias I definitely think it's
possible for one of the girls to be
involved I mean I don't trust anyone on
that show I think that there's been so
much dishonesty even between these girls
who try to be truthful with each other I
think that would be an interesting
choice I think it'd be so fun but the
only thing that I can't wrap my head
around is like how we would torture
ourselves so effectively you think that
it's possible that Allie after
everything she's been through is uber a
there's important to me that really
wants it to happen but I don't think so
no but what about someone else
well-known in Rosewood
I feel like Caleb could be a oh my god I
literally was just saying I would love
for that to happen he was really smart
yeah Caleb showed up halfway through the
first season mysteriously and he stuck
around and he's really good at computers
we've also been very involved with the
liars license and out yeah oh yeah I
want to be afraid I mean like everyone
wants to be brave they're like who's
afraid like me what can you tell me
about your return like is are they gonna
be shocked are the Liars gonna be
excited yes yes yes all of it they're
gonna be there completely shocked
they're not excited so maybe that's a no
but I do some terrible things like what
terrible things you're gonna not like me
which little liars gonna be the angriest
at me I'm like I'm the angriest um I
have a few scenes with Shane who plays
Emily and she doesn't like